non
mes chers compatriotes bonjour pardonnez
moi de venir dans ce printemps en plein
de promesses vous tenir à langage un peu
sévère savez le temps électoral c'est
celui où on annonce que tout va bien en
tous les cas que tout ira bien et sur
les écrans sur les tribunes les uns et
les autres essayent de vous convaincre
que tout le monde il est beau tout le
monde il est gentil sont bien sûr
l'adversaire et que demain tout sera
rose et bien moi je viens vous dire la
vérité je viens vous dire quelque chose
d'assez différent parce que quand
j'étais petit garçon il y avait une
chanson très célèbre juste avant le
déclenchement de la guerre qui
s'appelait tout va très bien madame la
marquise
et c'était une marquise qui apprenait
par le coup de téléphone d'un de ses
serviteurs que il s'était produit très
peu de chose dans le fond en son absence
simplement que sa jument était morte et
puis au fur et à mesure de la chanson on
apprenait qu'elle était morte dans
l'incendié les écuries elle même
provoquée par l'incendié du château et
le suicide de son mari
bon et bien en ce temps là ça se chante
et et on sait ce qu'il en était devenu
en 1939 45
et aujourd'hui ça se siffle
le français safran est en jeu c'est même
dans la cour ils étaient nombreux
c'est nier ce qui contraste n'est ce pas
entre l'air guilleret de la chanson et
la réalité que vous vivez vous
françaises et français tous les jours
relativement à tous ces grands problèmes
dont justement on ne vous parle pas ou
dont on ne vous parle quand masquant la
réalité du passé tout le monde
aujourd'hui vous parle de l'avenir
tout le monde vous dit ce qu'il va faire
pour vous rendre heureux
mais si vous étiez sage vous essayez de
demander et de vous renseigner sur ce
qu'ils ont fait les uns et les autres
or vous auriez l'occasion de vous
apercevoir que tous ces hommes qui
aujourd'hui sollicite votre confiance
on était dans les années précédentes les
responsables de la direction de ce pays
que ce soit monsieur chirac 74-76
monsieur bard 76 80
monsieur mitterrand de 80 à 88 et de
nouveau monsieur chirac de 86 à 88
ce sont eux qui sont directement
responsables de la situation dans
laquelle se trouve le pays aujourd'hui
situation donc beaucoup d'entre vous
souffre je le sais beaucoup d'entre vous
qui aspire à quelque chose de neuf à
quelque chose de vrai quelque chose de
sain un véritable avenir d'espoir en
quelque sorte alors je vais regarder
avec eux encore une fois en m'excusant
de la gravité de ce que je vais dire les
différents problèmes qui nous concerne
est d'abord celui sur lequel va se jouer
notre destin celui de l'immigration
étrangère dans notre pays regardez bien
cette courbe
voilà chirac barre mitterrand chirac en
on a interdit l'entrée de l'immigration
dans notre pays
depuis elle a progressé de plus de 2
millions autrement dit soit nos
dirigeants ont été impuissants à
endiguer cette marée soit ils en ont été
complices quelle confiance donc faire à
ces sommes et comment pourrait-il faire
demain ce qu'ils n'ont ni su ni voulu
fériés l'immigration étrangère tient
tant en quelques chiffres
et elle ne cesse de progresser il faut
que vous le sachiez 6 millions au moins
d'immigrés dans notre pays à un million
près les autorités ne savent pas à cause
des clandestins et à cause du flou qui
règne dans ce domaine plusieurs
centaines de milliers de chômeurs
étrangers assister un million d'enfants
étrangers dans nos écoles provoquant
d'ailleurs une grande partie le
phénomène de l'illettrisme de nos
enfants et puis ces milliers et milliers
d'étrangers qui viennent dans nos
hôpitaux se faire soigner par le biais
de ce qu'on appelle maintenant tant le
phénomène est généralisé le tourisme
sanitaire
même les prisons 30% de la population
pénitentiaire est d'origine étrangère et
30% supplémentaires sont en quelque
sorte des beurs des français d'origine
étrangère
devenu français par le système du code
de la nationalité
et il y encore beaucoup d'autres
phénomènes vous savez comme moi que les
français sont défavorisés dans le
domaine familial car on donne des
allocations familiales aux familles
étrangères au même titre qu'aux familles
françaises alors que nous avons besoin
de faire des enfants et que elles en ont
trop il en est de même pour l'aide
sociale et ceux qui ont malheureusement
besoin de cette aide sociale
s'aperçoivent qu'il ne fait pas bon être
français
en regard de ces administrations ou en
regard de la sécurité sociale organismes
d'ailleurs qui est en voie d'être ruinés
et qui légitime les craintes que nous
pouvons avoir les uns et les autres sur
la réalité de nos retraites de demain
alors il faut résoudre le problème de
l'immigration en inversant le courant de
l'immigration parce que si nous ne le
faisons pas nous allons être
progressivement submergé
non seulement par la marée sociale si je
puis dire mais aussi par la marée
religieuse par la marée culturel dont on
peut constater ici qu'elle progresse à
une allure extraordinaire et justifie la
parole de hussein moussaoui le chef du
hezbollah libanais qui déclarait il ya
peu de temps dans 20 ans et sur la
france sera une république islamique
et bien mes chers compatriotes comment
ne pas attirer votre attention sur le
fait que les étrangers qui viennent dans
notre pays y amènent avec eux leurs
moeurs leurs coutumes leurs croyances
n'adopte pas les nôtres et un jour si
nous n'y prenons garde nous les impose
rond comme ils le font au liban regardez
ce qui se passe en israël regarder ce
qui se passe en irlande
est ce que le monde multiculturel n'est
pas un monde dangereux
nous n'avions pas ces problèmes là en
france et ne souhaitons pas les avoir
moi en tout cas je ferai tout ce qui est
en mon possible pour que la france reste
française est sûre pour chacun d'entre
vous et puis dans d'autres domaines le
domaine de la fiscalité et des charges
qui est très important car il tient le
développement ou la ruine de l'économie
si vous regardez la flambée des charges
et des impôts vous vous apercevrez
qu'elle a progressé comme l'immigration
de la même manière et selon la même
pente sous les différents gouvernements
que ce soit la droite ou la gauche
mais qu'est ce que ça signifie ça ça
signifie que les français travaillent un
jour sur deux pour l'état pour la
collectivité
on comprend qu'il soit un peu démotivé
puisqu'il ne travaille plus qu'à moitié
pour eux or ce taux de prélèvements
obligatoires sommes des charges sociales
et fiscales
c'est celui qui conditionne notre
capacité de compétitivité économique par
rapport à nos concurrents étrangers
or nous sommes à 45 % l'étranger lui en
europe est à moins de 40% et hors
d'europe le japon la corée et les états
unis à moins de 30%
je le dis avec gravité mais avec
beaucoup de sérieux
si nous ne redresserons pas cette
situation redressement dont ont été
incapables les hommes dont j'ai parlé
et bien 92 sera ne sera pas austerlitz
mais va t he l'eau voyez vous c'est très
grave parce que si les entreprises
françaises ne se développe pas et bien
le phénomène du chômage continuera de se
développer
regardez bien encore cette courbe là qui
mesurent la montée du chômage depuis 14
ans et les responsabilités identiques
ils sont commandés aux courses des
dettes
ils sont sur la même ligne chirac barre
mitterrand en moyenne 700 750 1000
chacun voulez-vous me dire comment ces
hommes là qu'ils ont été incapables ou
impuissants seront capables demain de
donner du travail aux français
il vise mais ce n'est pas possible on a
fait tout ce qu'on a pu on n'a pas
réussi parce qu'on n'a pas voulu prendre
des mesures énergiques
parce que les idéologies s'oppose à la
prise de mesures nationales parce qu'on
n'ose plus penser nationale on n'ose
plus vouloir nationale alors moi je vous
le dis fais des solutions des solutions
qui comporte des choix aux ce serait
merveilleux si on pouvait tout faire si
on pouvait aider le monde entier moi je
choisi d'aider d'abord avec leur argent
les français ce n'est même pas de la
charité où la solidarité c'est de la
justice et en consacrant nos efforts
d'abord à inverser le courant de
l'immigration étrangère a fait rentrer
chez eux des gens qui étaient soi-disant
venu chercher du travail et qui n'en
n'ont pas qu'ils n'en ont pas trouvé
quoi de plus normal en réservant l'aide
familiale aux femmes françaises par
priorité est surtout la mesure que je
préconise de revenus maternelle pour les
mères de plus de trois enfants parce
qu'ils libèreraient autant d'emplois de
même à dire que la préférence nationale
permettra aux français de trouver du
travail ainsi qu aux européennes la cee
dans le camp dit qu'un tiers des emplois
disponibles ou au fur et à mesure qu'ils
sont libérés
et puis il ya d'autres mesures il y a
par exemple le foyer fiscal
bon ça permet de traiter les familles
comme des entreprises est comme les
entreprises de soustraire en quelque
sorte les charges et les salaires payés
à des aides familiales
exemple comme l'entreprise les soustrait
de son bilan en quelque sorte et bien
des mesures comme celle à court terme et
des mesures à long terme comme
l'amélioration de notre système
d'éducation nationale écoutez c'est tout
de même scandaleux que en 1988 y ait 20
% d'illettrés en sixième
ces jeunes enfants garçons ou filles
trouveront plus de travail dans la
société de l'an 2000 et dans les petits
travaux ils seront concurrencées par les
étrangers qui ne cesse d'entrer chez
nous cependant c'est tout de même par le
développement des entreprises que on
créera des emplois comme on l'a fait aux
états unis 8 millions dans les huit
dernières années ou en angleterre 500
milles dans les dernières années
il faut dit bhl parce qu'il n'ya que
l'entreprise qui crée des emplois mais
pour que se crée des entreprises faut-il
encore que les français que ce soit les
investisseurs les patrons les
entrepreneurs les ouvriers les cadres
les travailleurs les employés est en
envie de travailler il faut que les
agriculteurs n'ai pas le sentiment
d'être persécuté chassés de leurs terres
il faut que l'on ait de nouveau le goût
de vivre et comment elle va en
travaillant d'abord pour soi c'est
normal pour choix pour sa famille ont
fini par être démotivés quand on
travaille pour les autres et
exclusivement pour les autres charité
bien ordonnée commence par soi même
pour cela il faut aussi que nous
redonnions à notre pays une véritable
vitalité
nous ne faisons plus assez d'enfants et
vous savez bien la nature a horreur du
vide si nous ne faisons pas des enfants
français et bien d'autres qui sont en
train de venir les feront chez nous ils
sont en train de les faire chez nous et
moi je préfère que nous financions des
berceaux français plutôt que des
charters étrangle d'avions étrangers
voyez vous je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
plus beau creuser du bonheur individuel
que la famille c'est nécessaire pour
notre équilibre personnel c'est
nécessaire pour notre bonheur familial
mais c'est nécessaire aussi pour la
sécurité et la force du pays parce que
notre pays vieillit l'augmentation de la
population masque mal le fait qu'il y à
100 mille naissances étrangères par an
et 100 milles
naturalisé automatique par le système du
code de la nationalité
ils masquent mal que l'allongement de la
vie se traduit par un vieillissement de
la population et qui va payer les
retraites
il est évident qu'il faut faire là un
très considérable effort et je crois
qu'ils conjuguent à la fois l'espérance
de la france et l'espérance du bonheur
individuel
voyez vous mes chers compatriotes j'ai
essayé de faire avec vous le point sur
quelques questions fondamentales
évidemment je n'ai pas tout évoquée je
n'ai pas parlé du terrible danger du
sida dont vous savez j'ai été en quelque
sorte que le premier à avertir les
français nous n'avons pas parlé de la
drogue
huit cent mille drogués nous n'avons pas
parler du drame de l'agriculture
française réduite de six millions de
travailleurs à 800 milles et peut-être
demain à 500 milles mais je vous
proposerai des solutions là c'était
l'analyse c'était le bilan quelque sorte
du passé je vous dirais les raisons qui
lie à d'espérer dans l'avenir car si la
france veut manifester sa volonté
après avoir manifesté sa lucidité si
elle a le courage d'admettre que le
redressement et la renaissance ne
peuvent se faire que par l'effort de
tous mais par une direction elle aussi
clair et net
dites non au déclin dit non à la
décadence dit oui à la france forte à
pernel française